jetzt aber schmuse wünschen ihr dass
arbeitslose hühnchen
[Musik]
die pandemie hat die deutschen noch tier
verrückter gemacht ich brauche auch mal
wieder was zum kuscheln aber gewisse
ansprüche habe ich schon ich suche einen
hund mit hervorragendem stammbaum gut
aussehend gesund bereits erzogen und das
ganze als welpe ja das sind die wünsche
jeder hat von daher sitzt hier keine
ausnahme
wie realistisch ist dass ich würde jetzt
gern mitnehmen ja das ist gar nicht
realistisch weil das geht gar nicht weil
wir machen keine haustürgeschäfte
sondern sie müssen sich erstmal in ruhe
umschauen dann müssen wir gucken ob sie
uns passen
ob sie ab ich ihn fast merkel noch tabu
sind in ihren beinen stehe
glauben sie generell dass es nach dem
lockt ein problem geben wird dass viele
hundert wieder dass sie viele hunde
kriegen werden definitiv ist sie es ja
bei täglichen spaziergängen wie viele
leute jetzt mit welpen unterwegs sind
habe ich während des lockouts natürlich
vielleicht zeit bei home auch beim home
office aber danach auf einmal muss ja
normal in mein büro und dann sehe ich
auch da ist ja noch jemand und die
kinder sehen in der schule was macht er
jetzt den ganzen tag mit dem mund hält
die alle hunde oder gibts auch ohne die
gar nicht wählen weil das die meisten
hunde bellen ich sage immer wenn die
million hören da können wir ja eine
fremdsprache ja das wäre jetzt ein tier
was schön leise ist das hört stört
keinen nachbarn die welt nicht gut
welche ausbüxt könnt ihr der nachbar
schon probleme machen viele leute
schaffen sie sich solche tiere an wie
teuer ist die denn jetzt pro meter die
wären nicht pro meter gemessen sondern
das ist eine sache wo man uns
unterhalten müssen da haben wir keinen
festen preis für die vermittlung jetzt
stell dich nicht so an wenn er das kann
ich nicht
ja waren ja dann doch ein paar hunde
dabei welchen nehme ich jetzt mit oder
wie viele kann ich mit nimmt gar kein
der andere nicht mit stofftiere wir
haben uns mit lebenden objekten und im
augenblick halte ich kein tier was wir
haben geeignet wo man sie vermittelt zu
werden ich habe sie gar nicht nötig
herzschlag
ich gehe jetzt nämlich in die größte
tierhandlung der
welt und da war doch was sehen ob die
mir was verkaufen danke bitte
[Musik]
zeit sie haben die größte zur handlung
der welt wie viele tierarten geführt
haben ungefährt meistens um 3000
tierarten krass aber wenn ich mich hier
so umsehe würde ich schon sagen sie sind
die exotischen oder damit sich halt ich
bin ohne katja was würden sie mir
konkret empfehlen ich sehe da läuft
karten meerschweinchen lang was geben
sie den er zu füttern den
meerschweinchen dass sie so groß werden
ja ja und das ist wohl verwandt mit
meerschweinchen ist aber ein
wasserschwein wie sieht das bei ihnen
denn mit der garantieleistung auch hier
geben also bei uns im betrieb zwei
wochen voll garantie auf der tour aber
da ist natürlich so natürlich nicht bei
genickbruch oder so hat andere ist
natürlich die meisten kinder vom auto
zwei jahre gewährleistung ist darauf
alles ab werk in dem augenblick gilt bei
unserer muttertier als ab werk und wenn
er also da angeborenen herzfehler haben
der übersehen wird und habt ihr
lebenslang tabletten braucht dann
bezahlen wir die tiere shoppen mit geld
zurück garantie für mich als kunden
natürlich optimal für tierschützer ist
das eine schweinerei
ich hatte vor einer woche noch 35 runde
wir haben jetzt gehören auch sieben in
corona ja gibt es in deutschen
haushalten eine million mehr tiere wie
viel davon haben sie verkauft
ich glaube die haben ja nicht erzählt
ich schätze mal dass wir mehr als
hunderttausend tiere mehr verkauft haben
ich würde die zahl eher auf eine
viertelmillion was wir kriterien muss
ich denn erfüllen um bei ihnen jetzt ein
hund zu erwerben
ja da ist also im allgemeinen gespräch
war so am erhalt bis drei stunden dauert
drei stunden muss man mit ihnen erst mal
reden damit man so ein tier bekommt wenn
sie noch eine hinrunde hatten kann er
doch noch länger dauern
was machen sie denn dann den interessen
ja wir fragen wo sie herkommen wo sie
wohnen was sie arbeiten wie sie leben
wie viel zeit sie für das tierheim ist
ja das ist ja leicht ein russisches baby
zu adoptieren
da kann schon gut sagen ja ja obwohl da
würde ich ihnen aber auch von apparaten
auch da sind sie nicht für geeignete
meinung so ein quatsch ich leihe mir
einfach einen unbeaufsichtigten hund
der schutz entzogen ist so kaum zu
deinem neuen herrchen
[Musik]
so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich